- You are clutching this pole.
- Yeah.
- That is pole-clutch.
- I don't like it.
It looks like we're over the water,
I could just die.
- Do you drive a car everywhere?
'Cause.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
I drive a car everyday,
but not over water.
(rock music)
Time for another adventure!
Today, I'm in Santa Monica by the beach,
and I never come here.
I don't know anything about this place.
I live on the east-side of
town, it's a whole thing.
But, today I'm using Google Search to find
a cool place to eat,
a cool place to drink,
and something new to
do, all within one mile
of where I already am.
But first, I gotta find someone
to do it with, you know?
Make friends, right?
He gets it!
Say hi, how are you my friend?
See?
It's gonna be easy.
How's it goin'?
Hi.
They got lanyards.
Good morning.
- [Man On Bike] How you doin', man?
- Good, thanks.
Aw, he asked me how I was doin'.
Didn't stop to hear an answer.
But, he did ask how I as doin'.
(claps) Woo!
There's all these people working out, but
they're, I'll be honest, I
don't want a sweaty guest.
Good morning!
- [Woman] Hi!
- How are you doin'?
- Good, I have a question for you.
- Okay.
- Do you live live around here?
- Oh, in the valley!
Great!
So, you don't know much
about Santa Monica?
- No.
- Perfect!
Me neither.
- Woo!
- That's great, that's great.
There's a follow-up question.
If you have nothing else to do today,
do you want to hang out with me,
today and explore Santa Monica?
With my big ol' crew of people over there.
- Oh.
- See all those people, look
at how beautiful they are.
- Yes.
- Such attractive people I run with, eh?
- Yeah, it's for a video, obviously.
So it's not just, like a weird.
- Not like a stranger on the street.
- Right.
Are you hungry?
- Always.
- Any kind of food you would want to have?
- Mojitos is.
- That's not food.
- There's mint in it.
- There is mint, okay.
- Things that swim in the ocean, seafood.
- Seafood, yeah, I was thinkin' seafood,
I kinda tried, I lead you there but,
it's because I want seafood.
I was being selfish.
- You were baiting me, like a fish.
- But you can pick, oh, nice!
An early pun, we're in for a long day.
(laughs)
So if here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna type in seafood nearby.
There's one called The Lobster.
- Ah!
- Great!
Okay, let's go there.
- Okay!
- We'll get to know each
other, I'm Keith by the way.
- Taylor.
- Taylor, nice to meet you, Taylor.
Let's go, Taylor.
- Alright.
- Okay, so what I want to do is, also
have us eat things we've
never eaten before.
You, know you've never eaten here before,
but also like, what
have we not had before?
Anything that's shoutin'
out to you that you like?
- (laughs) Golden caviar,
is that a real thing?
- Well, yeah.
I've never had caviar at all.
- Golden color, neither have I.
(orchestra music)
- Wow, it's in a little jar.
- (laughs) Do we get to keep the jar?
- [Waiter] Yes.
- [Taylor] Yes!
- Could you tell us
- How to eat this.
- How to do it.
- I'm curious.
- [Waiter] I would get
a piece of this toast.
- [Keith] Uh-huh.
- [Waiter] And then, layer
up any acoutrements you like.
Put the caviar on top.
- Ready for this?
- Yep, cheers.
- Cheers.
(crunches)
(drum roll)
Oh wow!
- Living the dream!
- Oh, it's so good!
(chuckles)
I mean, I didn't want it to be that good.
- It's funny how good it is.
- Because I don't want.
- Now I'm gonna want to.
- To want to spend this kind of money.
But, it's so good.
- [Waiter] Here we have Peruvian Scallops.
- Oh, wow!
- Oh yum!
Look at those shells.
- Look at those, those are beautiful.
(slurps)
So, who are you?
What do you do?
What's your life?
- I am from Texas.
- [Keith] Oh!
- I'm really close to
being here for three years.
- I'm from Tennessee,
and I've been here for a
little over three years.
- [Taylor] Wow.
- How bout that?
- It's like we're the same person.
- No, no.
I milked a cow recently.
- What was the cow's name?
You got real fresh with that cow and
you didn't know it's name?
- Cow didn't seem to want to talk.
This is an engagement ring?
- [Taylor] Yes.
- That's very nice.
When did you get engaged?
- One month ago, yesterday.
- I'm engaged too.
- Heyah!
- And when I proposed I still
hadn't put on pants yet.
(laughs)
See what's the best thing to do?
Let's just do things.
- [Taylor] Adventure!
- To do in Santa Monica.
Santa Monica Pier.
Oh, the Santa Monica Pier,
that's probably (laughs)
the main thing to do.
- Rumor has it, it's where Route 66 ends.
- Really?
And then what are we gonna do?
What else are we gonna do?
- Drink.
- Yeah we're gonna drink.
(laughs)
- Where's a place to see a sunset?
I mean this is a good view,
but we're already here.
We've already done this.
- [Taylor] A rooftop?
- Oh yeah, roof-top bars.
We're in L.A.
We can do roof-top.
ONYX roof-top bar, okay.
Well, maybe we'll do more.
- What?
More?
- We'll do a little more.
(carnival music)
We're at the pier, look at this.
- Adventure time!
- It's beautiful!
You were totally right, great work!
Congratulations.
- I don't wan to rub
it in, but there it is.
- Well you kinda did like to rub it in.
Why did you eat the
whole thing in one bite?
- I don't know.
- That was foolish.
The people out in that
water, that must be freezing.
So do you like ferris wheels?
- Yes.
- Meh.
They're just.
- Rumor has it that they're
not, they're too safe for you.
- It's not that they're safe.
They feel totally unsafe.
(screams)
Alright, we're on the ferris wheel.
Oh boy.
- [Taylor] There's tiny little doors.
- Oh god!
It's awful!.
- You can just fall out of
these tiny doors at any time.
- Shut up, Taylor.
This is my, we're just slowly teetering.
Ready to plummet to our deaths.
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure
statistically way more
people have died on roller
coasters than ferris wheels.
- You don't know that.
But, it's nice.
The view is pretty, I
just wish we were in like,
a thing with windows and seat belts.
(chime music)
Well, we're on our way to the bar!
Roof-top bar!
- Woo!
- [Keith] It's been so
hot, such a long day.
I just want to unwind on a roof-top.
- Hi.
- How's it going?
- I'm here to help you, my name is Luis.
We're know for the Tamietini.
We made a drink after our
owner, her name is Tamie.
- Tamie!
- That sounds really
good, with basil in it.
- You know I think I might
lean towards the Ward eight.
- You'll love it, okay?
- Perfect.
- [Luis] I'll be right back.
- Thank you Luis.
I don't know if it was Luis
or Louis, but I was pulled.
- [Taylor] Did you say Luis?
- Uh-Huh.
- [Taylor] That's what I think it is.
- I just went for it.
What's your end goal?
What do you want most out of life?
You know, here we are on top of the world,
looking out over the whole world.
What do you want?
- I want to be happy.
- Boring.
- I want to be a lead in a sitcom.
- Nice.
- And I want to have an awesome marriage,
and I want to have a really cool family.
- How many children?
- I'd do two girls.
(laughs)
Her name is going to be Juniper.
- Of course, why not name
children after berries?
- Thank you.
- [Luis] You're welcome.
- It's beautiful.
- My drink looks far
more feminine than yours.
(laughs)
You know, to hopefully you get all
what you moved out here for.
- Cheers.
- Yum, mine's good.
How's the lady?
- It's delicious.
- The drink named after a lady.
- I'm gonna stir it with this basil leaf.
- Oh yeah, of course.
Look at that basil leaf.
So, what do you do after this?
How do we end such a perfect day?
Spending all this time out in nature,
out and enjoying the real world.
- Go and enjoy the fake world of movies.
- Yeah!
Any movie you want to see?
- Fantastic Beasts!
- Oh, I hear it's crazy visual.
Fantastic Beasts show times.
Maybe we'll check out the seven p.m.
at the ArcLight and have
ourselves a time of fantasy and.
- [Taylor] What a day!
- I know!
- Look at this day we've had.
- [Keith] It's gone.
- [Taylor] There it goes
and the birds fly free.
Thanks for a really solid Monday.
(laughs)
- That's pretty good.
(rock music)
Well' that's it, we did it!
Thanks to Google Search
found a new place to eat,
new place to drink, something new to do.
What a day, huh?
- [Taylor] What a day.
- We had a fantastic day
and now we're gonna go see
Fantastic Beasts!
- Yes and where to find them.
- We're gonna find all of 'em.
It's gonna be great.
But you can't come, you
can't film in the movies.
It's illegal, you know that.
You can't come in.
- Breaking the law.
- Just imagine we're having a great time.
We will be having a great time.
You guys just, you stay over there.
- [Taylor] Look how much fun we're having.
- A lot of people working out.
Not a lot of people want to be friends.